well we did the high points we got a Lum
we got to do below so at the end of a
video that I did last week going over
the best episodes written by former
Doctor Who showrunner Russell T Davis I
said that I was going to come back and
do the 10 worst episode zero and here we
are now a bit like when I talked about
his best episodes I do have to preface
this slightly and explain the man only
wrote 23 episodes and again I'm only
tackling episodes that he wrote himself
only I'm not including any episodes that
he wrote with a co-writer so that's only
23 episodes which means I barely got to
fill out on top on the bottom 10 so that
means some of the ones on the lower half
of this bottom 10 list are actually not
all that bad but this is still where
they're going to end up and I guarantee
that some people's favorite episodes are
going to be on this list so I might as
well just suck it up accept the fact I'm
gonna have a lot of people screaming at
me on the contents and let's get to it
with number 10 gridlock which hurt me to
put on here because I actually like
gridlock except I want to sort of take a
step back and remove it from my enough
house in the fact that it was one of the
early episodes that I saw and look at
the fact that it's a little goofy I'm
under starting premise it's actually
kind of awesome in terms of taking an
everyday thing and blowing up two sci-fi
proportions traffic jams are something
we've all dealt with imagine the
universe's worst traffic jam where
generations go by before a family can
get to an off-ramp that's it's kind of
Awesome but then there's a lot of the
fine details that bring it down first of
all we've got the cat people back again
we'll be revisiting them on this list
and while they're not as bad here as
they are a new earth again we'll come
back to that it's still a really goofy
concept the mock rub I kind of like the
nod but honestly this episode doesn't
need monsters they don't there's no
reason for them to be there other than
to insert I in force you know a couple
of whiz-bang action II tension kind of
moments I think this show needed that I
think I think the actual injection of
sort of light-hearted swashbuckling
is a knock against the concept I think
if they really wanted to roll with the
just a feeling of a traffic gym just the
oppressiveness of it would have been
much better to play that up over giving
us a monster we didn't need a monster
and another idea there and again it
factors into the explanation for why
this happened but the whole mood drug
thing that is such a good idea I feel
like you deserved its own episode and it
feels like a bit of a waste that it
ended up being thrown away as basically
a background explanatory element in this
episode so yeah because of those things
I do have to put gridlock on this list I
still like it but yep when I'm looking
at the man's work yeah it's a bottom 10
episode we'll be longing to number 9 the
runaway bride another one that I really
really wish I didn't have to put on here
because I love Donna I sent pretty much
every opportunity dawn is my favorite
companion Donna's the best but she's
grating in this one and she gotta have
to be for her art to work as a companion
but taking it in isolation this first
episode yeah it is painful is she's
obnoxious and she's irritating and we
get the return of the Santa robots which
again that's something I'm going to come
back to later in the list and the
racnoss is a really cool design but the
performance doesn't really work I think
my big problem with the racnoss Queen is
that as cool as she looks first of all
her performance is very over-the-top
which happens she was probably trying to
compensate for the makeup and the look
and try and bring a performance through
that but I really wish they had allowed
her to go into a booth afterwards and
dub over her dialogue because you can
really hear her struggling to get words
past those teeth they fit her with and
she talks and I kiss my children I would
be tired yes yes yes you can just hear
how much this teeth prosthetic is
inhibiting her speech and it drove me
nuts again there are some really good
moments in this I'm like especially the
doctors you know sort of going overboard
and drowning the racnoss and her and her
offspring and everything and Donna
taking that moment you know doctor you
can stop now I mean a doubly so given
the way that comes back in left turn but
again if I'm going to look at this
episode in isolation it it's just kind
of goofy and it's got enough things that
I'm like I know that pays off later but
right now looking at it here yeah it's
annoying yeah bug me number eight the
Christmas invasion see told you the fan
of robots we're coming back because just
did the same robots or da might at this
point I feel like with the Christmas
specials in general that if the episode
is not going to really excessively lean
into the Christmas thing like with
something like last Christmas or
Christmas Carol then I kind of want the
Christmas aspect to be relegated to the
background at best this sort of
enforceable insertion of a lot of
Christmas things like the killer tree
and the Santa robot suit it's painful
and it's the kind of thing that
thankfully I feel overall the show has
moved away from but that stuff's grating
now this episode does get good it gets
great in fact once David Tennant steps
out of the TARDIS in the last what 15
minutes of the episode up to that point
it's okay it's fine I mean where Rose I
go just like roses the companion but
most of what works about her is her
chemistry in the way she interacts with
at first Eccleston and then Tennant on
her own I don't think she doesn't work
for me I don't find her ticularly
compelling which he's not putting off
the doctor so the fact that we're stuck
with her and her mother who I'm not a
huge fan of for so long it's just yeah
it doesn't help and finally I think I
have come to the conclusion that I'm
kind of not really okay with what
happens to Harriet Jones I think that
her actions were completely reasonable
and I think the doctor overstepped and
not that I guess the reason it doesn't
sit with me is the doctor never admits
maybe I went too far with that because I
mean from what we know he effectively
robbed the universe of a Golden Age of
her leadership and he never makes any
apologies for her and I I get
you know it lends to his hubris which is
something pays off towards the end of
tenants run so I get all that it just
still bothers me I feel like the
character deserves better and I don't
like how it feel more cupon it feels the
fact that he did her wrong as far as I'm
concerned but again when Kenneth's on
screen it's great just that needed to be
more of the episode number seven to
think law again some good aspects I like
that David Tennant got to use his actual
accent for a little bit of it some fun
interactions with him and rose and and
all of that but I mean all right first
of all the the ninja monks in a campy
way it's kind of a fun image but it
doesn't really lend to anything and the
werewolf this is where the show's
budgetary restrictions really showed I
think in general doctor who needs to
avoid 100% CGI created creatures because
they never looked very good and the
werewolf didn't look great at the time
it aired and it has not aged well at all
it's the only reason it's not as bad as
say the Lazarus monster is because well
you know it's a werewolf we have a basis
for a werewolf that labs response was
just what the hell but it doesn't look
very good but again there are good
moments that I like didn't ends reaction
to it but ultimately that's kind of it I
like Tennant in it and Rose is fine in
it but the actual story doesn't really
grab me does it feel especially well
execute it's not particularly surprising
it's just kind of knit and then you
throw a you know very poorly aging CGI
effects heavy bit on top of that and
yeah it's it's one that I'm not too keen
to revisit music was good though number
six voyage of the Damned and I feel like
the drum I'm going to keep beating this
inside this entire video but good
elements good parts I like how or how
expansive the cast is I like that the
ones who survived were not the ones that
the doctor necessarily would have chosen
I like that one of the characters points
out well if you could choose who lives
in you guys think you'd be a monster
I like that moment I like will I loved
wills Astrid works pretty well as a
one-off companion but this thing kind of
knows us right
because we come into this off of a
cliffhanger of the Titanic the Titanic
crashes into the TARDIS and it it's not
the Titanic it's a ship it's a spaceship
that looks like the Titanic so that
that's a big cop-out for that a leaving
cliffhanger in the first place
and then while I do like how expansive
the cast is exactly how nuanced or how
you know involved I'm able to get with
these characters it very some of them I
can sort of gravity like you said Astrid
is quite good the guy who's the tour
guide I like quite a bit but most of the
other characters are pretty generic
bordering on cartoonishly broad in fact
and then there's things like the host
kill kill kill like and that's just that
is a tad too goofy that that feels very
much like a series one or two idea this
far into the into the show it felt like
that was the kind of idea the show had
moved on from at that point so it felt a
needlessly can't be needlessly goofy and
then then there's max Capricorn who he
talked about years ago on my worst one
off villains list because you know I use
the word cartoonish before that there is
no other word for that man I swear to
God he is a rejected Captain Planet
villain then that guy I just I can't
again good moments I lanzi Alonso Hey
but it says too much that's just number
five
boomtown hey it's the sleuthing you knew
they were going to show up on here so
there's basically one scene that I
borderline loved in this episode and
that is the dinner scene between the
doctor and that one remaining saline I
love that scene I liked their
interactions I like the way they wind
each other up I like that it feels
almost like I have electric clarice
starling scene and it's terrific
but the rest of it is just I want to say
it's kind of there since its kind of not
there's almost nothing else I even
remember from that episode I remember
they toned down the farting thank God
but you know the whole opening up the
TARDIS and she becomes an egg and I get
they had to set up the opening up the
TARDIS because of what happens
the parting of ways but like that weird
and random and her scheme is just kind
of a thing that she's doing and it I
couldn't even really tell you why at
this point it's just there's very little
of substance what this feels like
overall is this feels like a filler
episode this feels like okay we're not
ready for the finale yet we need another
episode in here oh let's revisit you
know there was a straggling Slovene and
there's our episode well what's she
doing what's what's the plot what the
actual thrust of the episode I don't
know where you just do something that's
that's what it feels like but we're not
done with the Slovene because number
four is aliens in London and world war
three which I suppose sirs of the
reminder I do too partisan only count
them as one story so again there are
moments specific moments that I love I
love that when the little pig thing gets
shot in the doctor skulls the soldier it
was scared and I love when the doctor
says information and they just start
shouting everything that they can
remember about the saline atom he's just
standing there going there's a town
narrows it down I love that stuff that's
actually some of my favorite stuff
during Eccleston's run but then Parris
arting aliens who do this slow unzip and
I get it the first time for the reveal
but like every time is like why are
people just standing there staring at
you as you do the slow unzip on your
head and the farting and the farting and
the burning and I get that it's like
it's meant to be a parody and it's
belittling to government but it's just
it's is there a less nuanced way to
dress somebody back down than with a
friggin fart joke I don't like how
shoehorn the whole turning Mickey into
this actor thing because of this one
password that unlocks everything that
the doctor happens to know what that's
just cheap lazy writing an attempt to
force Mickey to be helpful when he just
wasn't at this point and there's another
moment that I kind of hate and it comes
off what should be a triumphant moment
for the doctor because he he's backed
against the walls like never backed me
against the lips and the elevator doors
open he steps back and he gets away
none of people who are right there
just stick a hand out to stop the door
from closing and stop the lift from
leaving what they just stand there at D
step it has to open all the way yes to
step in they have to go even if I accept
the idea that an elevator door closes
immediately after someone steps into it
which never happens they still open and
close at this pace nobody stopped it
nobody just stuck a hand in between the
what really really again and that just
lends itself to lazy writing and a lazy
way to get out of the situation it's
just like I said there's a handful of
moment basically having to do with the
doctor himself that are good quite good
and Harry Jones is good but man the
stuff that's not good in this episode's
there or is really not good number three
the long game so there's pretty much one
thing that this episode does right as
far as I'm concerned and it is named
Simon Pegg I am a sucker for Simon Pegg
I give the man a lot of leeway as far as
I'm concerned he elevated the episode
and he functioned much better as a
villain than the friggin jagrafess but
he's kind to ish this it was weird sort
of going back and looking at it again
because this is the only episode I can
think of where Eccleston's heart doesn't
feel like it's in his line reading like
he's got this line you know take these
manacles off me and I'll show you how
much fun I am or whatever it is that he
says and like it's so half-hearted which
suddenly I never got from him in any
other episode it feels like the one time
that the aggravation of the stuff that
was going on behind the scenes at the
time sort of seeped into his performance
and it's the only time I get that so
he's not quite working for me in this
episode we're stuck with that and
Mitchell who I get as a concept in terms
of here's a real crap companion to
explain why Rose is so good and how her
rolling with the doctors are something
everyone can do I get that but he's
still annoying to deal with
you've got the jagrafess which it's a
mountain the ceiling and I talked about
him on my worst villains list because
it's just it's the epitome of insert
monster here it's just so bland and
generic and like I said the editor is a
way more
compelling villain we didn't mean that
and overall the image was just slow and
boring doctor who is not often boring at
least not for me but this one kind of is
number two new earth Oh series to you
you had a rough start didn't yet so
where do we begin first of all I feel
like in some ways Tennant didn't quite
have his feet under him yet he's fine
he's not bad in this but he hasn't quite
he isn't quite nailing it on all fronts
the way that he is in some of the later
episodes and the way in which he can
elevate sometimes not so great because
I'd like to get with the Christmas
invasion I feel like you really knew how
to play the doctor coming right out of
regeneration but this first adventurer
is supposed to kind of settled into a
thing he doesn't seem like he's quite
there yet I mean again it's not a bad
performance but it doesn't he doesn't
quite feel comfortable in the role quite
yes
and then we've got the we have the cat
people and look that the design is fine
the makeups fine as far as these things
go but for all the amazing fantastical
things it just bothers me when sci-fi
shows like this just take an earth
animal and slap its face onto a human
actor that is just such a lazy way to
design a alien race it's the same reason
I can't stand the half because it's just
it's just a fish head it's like that's
not an alien that's something I know
just stretched into a person give me
something I've never seen before give me
something that doesn't make immediate
logical sense where I know oh well
that's a fly in a boiler suit that's a
fish with a water mouth breather as a
cat as a nurse and then there's
Cassandra which i think was a really
weird choice to do a recurring villain
out of because first of all considering
how her death was pretty definitive and
the toss off joke line explaining her
coming back is kind of weak I do add
mentioned this before I do like to kind
of coda they get for her character at
the very end with a looping back and you
know
and her in that other guy's body that's
fine but the whole body swapping thing
also doesn't really serve much of a
purpose as far as plot or anything else
goes but it also results into this total
whiplash because you get the standard
goofy humor you expect out of a body
swapping thing but then you've got these
people being bred to be just be diseased
and live this horrific light and they
give release to infect people with did
multitudes of diseases and it ah this is
a this a mix of elements that don't gel
they just kind of clash against each
other and nothing is nothing is really
working nothing is interlacing and even
the ideas that are here aren't
particularly good ones but it is not in
my opinion the number one worst episode
that Russell T Davies ever wrote so that
brings us to number one now I got to be
honest this list was actually really
hard to order except for figuring out
number one number one was an easy choice
and I know this episode has its fans but
I think even those fans knew that this
was coming
number one love and monsters homeboy
I've said it before I get the idea I get
the concept of this episode in terms of
you know not only being a doctor light
episode but being sort of a commentary
on fandom and how fandom can start out
one way and be twisted into something
that is more destructive I get that it
still doesn't work first of all if
you're going to do a doctor by episode
you have to be sure that whatever
characters you are focusing on instead
of the doctor are as compelling as the
doctor is to make up for that gap that's
why turn left works because we've got
done and we've had dawn for a while
we've gotten to know and to like Donna
that is why blink works because Sally
Sparrow is a well written character who
we get to know Elton and the entire rest
of these fans are not compelling
characters they're not engaging so they
don't pick up the slack in the fact that
we don't have the doctor that's the
first thing then there's
six we absorb along and again I get that
they were kind of stuck in terms of the
general design and the concept of this
thing because a kid won a contest and
it's a very you know it's the kind of
design a kid would come up with but you
know they could have tried I feel like
they just slap this guy soon the fact
that he runs around going it's like
you're not even trying and then there's
the weird highly appropriate joke at the
end of the thing there's a like that you
know while I understand that it's trying
to be a commentary on fandom it doesn't
feel like it's laughing with the fans it
feels like it's laughing at the fans it
space weird the characters aren't
interesting there's no sense of state
because the characters aren't
interesting now the characters we care
about are in jeopardy
there's like a couple of curls on the
conceptual level that okay maybe there's
something there but aside from that
nothing here works and that is why I've
got to say love and monsters was the
worst episode that Russell T Davis ever
wrote so there you go that's my list I
have no doubts that people if you have
not already flagged me off in the
comments are prepared to do so and I'm
sure some of you disagree but if you
could you know not be overly rude about
it feel free to disagree with me or to
agree with me or whatever whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter a council of geeks give a listen
to the council of geeks podcast or I am
also one half of beep punch like a girl
podcast both of those are available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]